[Music]
listen bub
Wolverine might be number seven on my
list of the 463 coolest comic characters
but his implausible backstory really
gets under my skin I'm not talking about
the fact that Marvel created a superhero
with special mutant healing power and
then decided that he was from Canada a
country was socialized medicine no I'm
talking about the explanation for the
footlong claws in wool these arms when
Len Wein first created Wolverine the
claws were just part of his costume but
when he turned up in the revamped x-men
the claws turned out to be metal
implants of course they never got around
to explaining how he got this elaborate
system of artificial muscles and tendons
it would have been required to extend
and retract them it's implausible but
not unforgivable
what's unforgivable is the way the
recent comics in the current movie
series introduced a retcon retroactive
continuity change duh that made his
talons far more dubious now we're to
believe that Wolverine was born with
claws made out of bone that were later
coated with the indestructible metal
adamantium so that makes him totally
natural and much easier to swallow right
wrong because there's no such thing as
bone claws mammals have claws made out
of keratin not bone
hey you boneheads at Marvel I have an
idea for a new superhero Tibbie a man
when danger is near he pops out his shin
bones and whacks baddies with them it's
preposterous I mean how are we expected
to okay but I mean excreting bones in
combat that's so ridiculous that they
would never never never
okay I surrender I can't think up a
superhero more anatomically idiotic than
that join the a na angry nerd army
I'm your general I'm looking for a few
good nerds enlist with a video reply
today